the only person that i ever got
starstruck and i worked with all of them
the biggest stars
the only person i could never get over
who he was was frank sinatra wow wow
only one you've been on set with sophia
vergara not starstruck even a little bit
she's a beautiful person
what was the interaction
it's not sofia loren yeah it's a very
big exactly
every time i was with him
i would just kind of just put my head
down and go frank's so natural
i couldn't get over
i just couldn't get over who he was he
was the only one because he was like to
me
you know i it's the famous it's a famous
story i told it on a tonight show and
it's in a book
it's and that's when we were sitting
there we everybody went inside and i was
at a barbecue at frank's house this one
time i'm sitting there with him and also
he goes uh
hey charles you know bronstead's one of
my favorite movies i said oh thanks
frank he goes it was a great movie i
said thanks frank he goes you know why
it was a great movie and i'm like why
frank he goes because i didn't [ __ ]
fall asleep
that's what he said he went back so then
he goes to me he goes uh
and we're talking and having a great
time and he's got he's got a martini
with two olives in it
did i ever tell you this no so he takes
the he takes the two pick out
with the two arms and at the end and and
he goes chest come on share my owl and i
said what he goes
go ahead take dialogue share it with me
so i didn't know what he was doing so i
took the olive off the toothpick and he
goes you ready i go yeah and we pop the
arms and i'm out and he hugs me goes i
love you man you're a good kid you know
you're always welcome to come around
frank sinatra
wow whatever so i said i said well
thanks frank he goes come on let's go
inside everybody's eating waiting for us
i said all right we walk inside and
everybody's you know serving they're
serving a
smorgasbord of food
and all of a sudden i go up to uh
don rickles
oh my god don rickles was there with oh
my god steven edie gourmet don rickles
dinero was there and a couple other i
think sean connery was there too so i
walk over there and i and i go his name
just come out of your mind yeah and i go
over there and i go hey i go what's with
this
with this this olive thing frank just
never did that before to me what's that
about
right and i hear a voice behind me go
frank sharon allah with you
and i turn around and it's gregory
gregory peck the great actor
they were best friends him and frank
so i said yeah what's this this olive
thing
he goes that's a sign of great
friendship jazz the rat pack would share
their olives together after they drank
martinis and it's a sign of being a bond
yeah
he goes if frank did that with you
welcome to the club that's incredible i
was blown away that's incredible i was
blown away what an experience how did
you handle limelight because sometimes
when you go from overnight
and now the world knows who you are
that's a that's dramatic that's not a
little bit you know how do you how do
you imagine that i just managed it you
know i just managed i'm like was it hard
sometimes yes
did
sometimes you just got to go you know
okay i'm cool
you know i'll be all right you know you
just gotta
you know i don't forget i was 38 40. so
i wasn't a kid
anybody who makes it under the age of 20
or 30 is is insane yeah so i was already
seasoned
but even me even at my age it was still
like you know all of a sudden you you
have you know all these people want
something from you you know i was always
you know i i i always had girls so it
wasn't like i never had girls before
you know but it's just this constant
level of women and and money and people
and
and what would sound horrible what saved
me was no but believe me what saved me
was i i had a beautiful i met a
beautiful girl
my wife and i got married right around
the time bronxdale was coming out so
people go my friends are going what are
you crazy you're getting married
are you out of your mind yeah you know
and i said look man i've had a lot of
pretty girls i've got i grew up i've had
a lot of women in my life you know do
you believe in the in the three great
women in your life no question
no question i believe that you know i
mean that's one of my things that's how
i wrote it in look think about how many
times have you felt think about it how
will you know you guys are younger
how many times have you fell in love in
your life think about it once
twice twice sir maybe twice that's it
three times three three times is like
forget it you only get three atoms once
a week but yeah every week
you gotta listen to my podcast because i
talk about this whole thing about it
with sandy blue eyes come on no no they
come around every 10 years like great
fighters
exactly but here's the thing about that
is yes could you have all the women in
the world but some of the biggest ladies
men in the world are very lonely yeah
you know very lonely you know happiness
is is marriage and meaning of family and
being you know look is it hard yeah but
that's the way life is
chaz what is the modern day
door test
in the movie you said
you know what you're going to do the
test she orders the uber okay
and she goes oh
and they go oh the morning the money
as soon as the door closes she has to
get the automatic thing on her side and
hit it a few times so the button goes
quickly quickly
now in the old days you have to lift it
up but now
but now with social media and dating
apps i gotta tell as as comedians you
know don rickles is is as good as it
gets and you talked about frank sinatra
one of the funniest stories i ever heard
that don rick was talking about marriage
he's like he was explaining i believe it
was to carson how he fell in love with
his wife and i guess he was married for
a very long time so he finds this girl
he's madly in love with and he's begging
frank sinatra he's like frank i got this
it's a great story we want to make it
with yeah i want to make it with this
girlfriend i told you this story
yes he's like you got you got to coach
you want to take the story wow okay sure
i mean yeah it's fine he says uh frank
you're the biggest star in the world
right uh do me a favor i'm going to have
dinner with this girl
and just come by and say hi and he's
like i'm not going to come by
i'm not going to do this come on frank
please come on have a little response i
want to i want to help you help me out
here [ __ ] frank sinatra don listen
i'm not coming over to your table it's
like just leave me alone don please
all right okay don rickles i'll come so
frank she's 10 o'clock don't be late 10
o'clock exactly he sets it up i'll be
with the girl
and it's all right frank sinatra i'll
come over to your table and say hi and
frank sinatra comes over to don reckles
tables hey don how you doing don goes
frank i'm having dinner
what are here doing interrupting my
dinner that's him and that's uh it's
like
he said frank sinatra
you're kidding me no it's like the best
downward experience oh i can tell you i
can tell your wrinkle stories he says he
goes you know frank's three wives were
all named joanne
wow despite i didn't know that he goes
you know frank he goes you know my frank
picks all he's doing he goes chief
bastard doesn't want to change the bed
tower
jay carson jay claus so he goes let me
tell you something chad oh i could i
could go once this is rickles this is
rickles he was one of a kind by the way
the rickles goes to me goes you know
rick will save my life
you know sinatra says this no rickles is
saying sinatra say
save my life rickles is telling me i
said really he goes yeah i said i said
donna you seriously
saved my life
i said what happened he goes 1967 front
of caesar's palace three guys stopped
beating me over the hell with baseball
bats
beating the [ __ ] out of me frank walks
out and says that's enough
[Laughter]
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]